now in the uk a serving police officer
has been charged
with the kidnapping and murder of a 33
year old woman
wayne cousins who's 48 made his first
appearance
at a london court on saturday morning
sarah everard's body was found hidden in
woodland
more than a week after she went missing
it's believed she was attacked
while walking home from a friend's house
in south london
her disappearance and killing have
caused a nationwide
outcry and prompted a global discussion
around
women's safety and for more let's bring
in our correspondent
charlotte cheslin pill in london
charlotte good to see you this isn't
the first murder of a woman in the uk
what is it about
sarah everard's case that's triggered
such a passionate
reaction and debate about women's safety
i think first of all you'd have to
mention some of the the chilling
details about this case which are still
emerging of course you described them
there just now
about the the man who has been arrested
in connection
uh with her murder a police officer or
clearly
an alarming development but
this case is something that every woman
certainly in the uk
has been able to relate to she was
walking home from a friend's house when
she went missing and
women can all relate to that they can
relate to the fear of walking home alone
at night uh women everywhere on social
media
on television in parliament here in the
uk now
sharing stories of that fear that they
experience everyone
is sharing how they would carry keys in
their hands as they're walking home how
they've sped up in the past if they've
felt like someone is is following them
how they've changed their route home
and that is a conversation now that is
happening on a national
level so much uh has this uh tragic
story grip the nation there was a vigil
planned
for this evening that's now been
cancelled due to coronavirus
restrictions but instead
uh donations are coming in thick and
fast for women's charities and of course
this hasn't just uh affected uh women in
the uk this is a global issue there is
now a global conversation with women
sharing
uh just how they've felt uh in the past
as they they
walk home and of course part of that
conversation is now women saying there's
got to be a shift in the conversation
from urging women to be cautious to
changing men's behavior
right there is a conversation happening
about refocusing the lens here
not just looking at why are women
getting harassed on the street or
sexually harassed
but why is this being perpetrated by by
some men now
men are joining in this conversation
seen a lot of posts on social media
where they're asking
how can they help how can they make
women feel more comfortable if they
do find themselves on a street with a
woman who is uh
on their own so this is something that
men are now participating in
but this is about re refiguring how we
look at cases like this i think a lot of
men coming out on social media saying
they weren't
aware of the scale of the fear that a
lot of women
fear on a regular basis all right
charlotte chelsea pill reporting from
london thanks so much
you